- Guasca : à une quarantaine
de kilomètres de la capitale,
Bogota, était à portée de la
guérilla des FARC à son apogée
90. Elle a déposé les armes
il y a cs.s.s.s.
La paix, quoiqu'imparfaite,
a bien changé le paysage
On peut se dire de gauche sans
êupupupupçonné de sympathies
avec des terroristes. Et depuis
trois ans, les Colombiens ne se sont pas gênés
pour exprimer leur colère
contre le gouvernement sortant
Ce fonctionnaire municipal
prévoit une plus forte
Cette élection promet un vrai
changement.
Tout ça explique la popularitéi,
Gustavo Petro, dans un pays
200 ans. Ancien guérillero
du M19, député, sénateur,
maire de Bogota, il a une longue
à former une coalition de
gauche, le Pacte historique.
"Le choix, dit-il, c'est encore
et de faim ou bien changer
la Colombie".
Le trouble-fê
homme d'affaire de 77 ans,
ancien maireamamamamamamanga,
Rodolfo Hernandez.
Ses advers
comme un populiste de type
DonaldJaJaJaJaJaJair Bolsonaro
du Brésil, en moins explosif,
ma
dans les médias sociaux.
a a a a a a faire la différence,
c'est le taux de participation,
en Colombie. Le vote des jeunes.
Jean-Michel Leprince
Radio-Canada, Guasca